hey everyone welcome to Simply learn
today we will learn the SQL interview
questions and answers that said if these
are the type of videos you'd like to
watch then hit that subscribe button and
the bell icon to get notified just for a
quick info if you want to upscale
yourself master data science and
analytics skills and land your dream job
or grow in your career then you must
explore simply learns goad of various
data science and analytics programs
simply learn offers various
certification and postgraduate programs
in collaboration with some of the
world's leading universities like
Caltech Purdue IIT conour and many more
through our courses you will gain
knowledge and work ready expertise in
skills like Advanced Excel Advanced
python machine learning data
visualization generative Ai and over a
dozen of other skills that's not all you
also get the opportunity to work on
multiple projects and learn from
industry experts working on top TI data
and product companies and academicians
from top universities after completing
these courses thousands of Learners have
transitioned into a data science or data
analytics rule as a fresher or moved on
to a higher paying job and profile if
you are passionate about making your
career in this field then make sure to
check out the link in the pinned comment
and description box below to find a data
science and data analytics program that
fits your experience and areas of
interests now without further delay
let's get started with the first
question in the docket so the first
question is what is SQL and what is the
order of SQL query execution so the
answer for this question is SQL or
structured query language is a
programming language designed design for
managing and manipulating relational
databases it is used to perform
operations like querying data updating
data inserting data and deleting data
from a
database and the correct order of
execution of a SQL query is as follows
it starts a SQL query execution starting
from the from Clause followed by that
the we Clause then Group by having
select order by and limit now with that
let's move ahead to the second question
what is the difference between SQL and
no SQL databases the answer is SQL
databases are relational databases that
use a structured schema and are suitable
for complex query intensive transactions
no SQL databases are non-relational and
are suitable for large amounts of
unstructured data and real-time
applications now moving ahead we have
the third question explain the
difference between inner joint and left
joint the answer for this question is
inner joint returns only the row where
there is a match in both tables where
left joint returns all rows from the
left table and the Matched rows from the
right table if there is no match null
values are return for columns from the
right table now let's move ahead into
the fourth question what is
normalization and
denormalization the answer is
normalization is the process of
organizing data in a database to reduce
redundancy and improve data Integrity
denormalization on the other hand is the
process of combining tables to minimize
the number of joins for query
optimization now the fifth question
explain the asset properties in the
context of a database asset stands for
automac consistency isolation and
durability these properties ensure that
database transactions are processed
reliably automac City ensures that the
transaction is treated as a single
indivisible unit consistency ensures
that a transaction brings the database
from one valid state to another
isolation ensures that concurrent
execution of transactions does not
interfere with other and and durability
ensures that once a transaction is
committed it remains committed even in
case of a system failure now moving
ahead we have sixth question what is the
difference between group buy and having
Clauses the answer for this question is
Group by is used to arrange identical
data into groups typically to perform
aggregation functions on each group
whereas on the other hand having is used
in in combination with group y to filter
the results based on a condition applied
to grouped data now 7th question explain
the difference between union and Union
all the answer for this question is
Union combines the results of two select
statements removing duplicate rules
while Union all combines the results
including duplicates now the eth
question what is a subquery the answer
for this question is a subquery is a
query nested within another query it can
be used to retrieve data that will be
used by the main query as a condition to
further restrict the data to be
retrieved now the ninth question how can
you prevent SQL injection in your
queries the answer is SQL injection can
be prevented by the following steps to
prevent SQL injection use parameterized
queries or prepared statements
these methods ensure that user input is
treated as data and not as an executable
code now 10th question explain the
difference between a primary key and a
foreign key the answer is a primary key
uniquely identifies each record in a
table and must be unique and not null a
foreign key is a field in a table that
is a primary key in another table
establish lishing a link between the two
tables now the 11th question what is the
difference between a wear clause and a
having Clause the answer for this
question is the wear Clause is used to
filter rows before they are grouped and
aggregated whereas the having Clause is
used to filter the results of aggregate
functions applied to grouped rows now
the 12th question explain the concept of
indexing in databases the answer is
indexing is a database feature that
improves the speed of data retrieval
operations on a database table by
creating a data structure also known as
an index on one or more Columns of the
table indexing allows the database
engine to quickly locate and access the
rules that satisfy a query now the 13th
question what is a stored procedure the
answer is a stored procedure is a precom
filed collection of one or more SQL
statements that can be executed as a
single unit it is stored in the database
and can be called and executed by
another program or another procedure now
the 14th question how can you find the
second highest or nth highest salary
from a table the answer is you can use
order buy and limit Clauses to find the
second highest salary for example select
salary from employees order by salary
descending limit one or offset one in
case if you wanted the nth highest
salary then provide offset n let's say
if you wanted to get the fifth highest
salary then provide offset five now
moving ahead we will discuss the 15th
question explain the difference between
a primary key and a unique key the
answer is both primary key and unique
key enforce the uniqueness of values in
a column but a table can have only one
primary key whereas it can have multiple
unique Keys moving ahead we have the
16th question what is a view in SQL the
answer is a view is a virtual table
based on the result of a select query it
does not store the data itself but
provides a way to represent the data
stored in one or more tables in a
specific way now 17th question what is
the purpose of SQL case statement the
answer is the case statement is used to
perform conditional logic in SQL queries
it allows you to perform different
actions based on different conditions
now 18th question how can you update
data in a table using SQL the answer is
the update statement is used to modify
the the existing records in a table for
example update employees set salary is
equals to 50,000 where department is
equals to ID so you are giving an update
command to table name employees and you
want to set salary equals to 50,000
where department or Department column is
equals to the value it now 19th question
explain the difference between a
clustered index and a non-clustered
index answer a clustered index
determines the physical order of data
rows in a table and a table can have
only one clustered index a non-clustered
index does not affect the physical order
of the rows and can be created on
columns other than the primary key now
moving ahead we have the 20th question
what is the purpose of SQL join Clause
the answer is the join Clause is used to
combine rows from two or more tables
based on a related column between them
there are various types of joins
including inner join left join right
join and full join each serving a
different purpose in combining data from
multiple tables now moving ahead we have
another five questions from SQL
interview questions and answers these
five questions will be based on query so
the interviewer might ask you or might
give you a realtime situation where you
might have to extract the required
results using a SQL query so the
following questions are 21st write a
sequal query to retrieve the total
number of rows in a table the answer for
this question is Select count Star as
total rowes from your table name so here
you are trying to select
the count function and star indicates
select all the rows in your particular
table and name the result as total rows
from the given table let's say your
given table is department so select
count Star as total Row from department
now moving ahead 22nd question write a
SQL query to find the average salary of
employees in a specific department so
here a specific spe ific Department from
an employee data table will be provided
to you and that particular department is
to be selected and you need to find the
average salary of all the employees
present in that particular department
for example someone might get 50,000
someone might get 100,000 right so the
average salary of employees is 75,000
here so you need to find out the average
salary number so the answer for this
question is Select
average of salary as average salary from
employees where department is equals to
the given Department let's say the
interviewer asked you to find out the
average salary from testing department
so you are going to write select average
of salary and name the result as average
salary from employees data table where
department is equals to testing and
remember the testing word should be
includ included in single codes because
it is character data type so you can
either add that particular text in
between single codes or double codes so
remember whenever you are using text
based data try to include it in single
codes or double codes now moving ahead
we have next question write a SQL query
to display the top five highest paid
employees from a table so here the
question might be the fifth highest or
get all five top highest understand the
question properly and write the answer
so the answer for this question is
Select employee ID employee name salary
from employees data table order by
salary in descending order limit five so
in this particular situation the
salaries are or the data will be
organized in descending order that is
highest salary first second highest
third highest fourth highest and fifth
highest so entire data will be printed
but you are trying to limit the values
or the result to only five rows using
the limit query so here select employee
ID employee name salary from employees
data table order by salary descending
order limit five is the answer now 24th
question write a SQL query to update the
salary of all employees by a 10%
increase
so here you are trying to update a
particular column which is the salary
column so you want to increase the
salary of each and every employee by 10%
right so in that situation you might
want to multiply the salary number with
another number which is 1.1 which is
also in terms of 10% increase so the
answer for this question is update
employees table set
salary column is equals to existing
salary value into number 1.1 this should
do the job now the last question in our
list for today write a SQL query to find
the second most common value in a column
the answer for this question is set your
column from your table Group by your
colum order by count descending limit
one offset one these questions test your
ability to construct SQL queries from
common tasks including data retrieval
aggregation updating records and working
with ordering and limiting results
practice writing and understanding these
type of queries to enhance your SQL
skills and with that we have come to the
end of this session on SQL interview
questions should you need any assistance
PPT and other resources used in this
session please let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
experts we'll be happy to help you as
soon as possible until next time thank
you for watching and stay tuned for more
from Simply learn staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to ner up and get certified click
here